well meantime celebrating a major
milestone a local animal rescue has
saved
5 thousand lives and tonight they're
grateful for all the support across
southern nevada
hearts alive village has helped so many
pet owners keep their furry friends at
home
during the most challenging months of
the pandemic with programs like pet food
pantry
an affordable full-service veterinary
clinic and a network of foster parents
pets have been able to stay with their
loved ones or in cases where parents
need to surrender their furry babies
hearts alive village make sure they go
to great homes
we've offered support over the last year
with our pet food bank
and it's getting better you know
the economy is coming back here and we
had so many fosters
and a lot of adopters during that time
people looking for companionship
so we've created a whole bunch of
families and we're helping to keep them
together
hearts alive village says the 5 000
lives saved only account for pets who
have entered the rescue's rehoming
program
and does not include those who have been
helped through the community support
initiatives